LOOSE PUCKS TRYING TO FIND SOME
RYAN PALING ABLE TO TAKE HIM UP
AHEAD KEEGAN KOLESAR TRYINGNG
A COUPLEDOWN.
SAVED BY LEHNER.
REBOUND SCORE. UP AFTERWARDS.
HAVE BEEN FEW AND FAR BETWEEN.
OPPORTUNITY  FORCOGHLANTE TRANS
AND EVEN STRENGTH.
STEPHENSON POSSESSION.
GO.
A BACKEND SCORE. LITTLE
TOO FAR UP SHY.
TAKES ITOF THAT
DOWN LOW
FRONT.
WITH THE PUCK STILL LOOSE.
SUZUKI GETS IT OUT THE OTHER
SIDE.
TOFFOLI SOME QUQU
BACK THE OTHER WAY.
DVORAK FEEDS IT.
SHOT, SCORE.
A LITTLETHE
CANADIENS IN THIS GAME.
OR TIME BUT HE SNAPPED IT RIGHT
AWAY WITH A THEIR LAST MAN
ADVANTAGE.
MARCHESSAULT SCORES.
JONATHAN MARCHESSAULT
HE WILL FEED IT UP THE WIWI IN
50 SHOT MARK TONIGHT FOR THE
SEVENTH TIME ININ
NOW OFF ICE  COMES SUZUKI.
SUZUKI WITH STEPHENSON. OUTWEIG
PETRI WITH THE RIGHT AWAY. DORE
SHOOTS A